[Music]
versus I have a bag that I found that I
think belongs to got a headache
Oh bless your heart where did you find
it on the subway Oh would you like a cup
of coffee you're being so kind I don't
get many visitors you know I've been so
lonely since my daughter left well I
could help you
my mom actually used to say I'm like
chewing over here I didn't stick around
[Music]
did you find them
I guess she's been cleaning bags around
the city is hoping someone brings them
back to her and just did oh my god is
her just let it ring
I saw the bags better I never want to
see you again she's really freaking me
out
this is not a problem public area our
rights are protected why are you doing
this how exciting
hi I'm princess all your waitress for
the evening no I can't do this
oh you child whom you the child you need
a mother to hold you don't you dare talk
to me about my mother everyone needs a
friend
between more than friends we're
connected
there's something you need to know about
beretta are you insane
[Applause]
just try to get rid of Greta
[Music]
you